There's definitely been a lot of talk
of,
of the young Brooklyn writer,
and then there's now been the backlash
for sure.
Um,
you know,
I got called the Brooklyn Writer,
uh,
not too long ago,
and I was torn between a sense of pride
or a sense of embarrassment because now
it's become such a thing.
Um,
I think we again,
have to think of why that phenomenon
exists,
right?
Brooklyn was initially a cheap
neighborhood for writers to live and you
could have space and you could probably,
most importantly,
you'd have your own office,
which,
which is what I have now in my current
place in Brooklyn.
I have a nice office.
I wouldn't have been able to get that in
Manhattan at the modest price and I'm
paying.
So there's those considerations.
Um,
but then,
you know,
you get enough artists and writers
moving to neighborhood,
uh,
the,
the thing begins to brand itself,
um,
probably originating in a sense of
pride,
right?
People saying,
well,
yeah,
you know,
we're Brooklyn Writers and this is a
thing and,
you know,
trying to defend themselves and then it
becomes a sort of embarrassing brand.
Um,
so yeah,
there's,
there's times you,
you have to sort of say it with a smile,
you know,
that you're a Brooklyn writer,
but,
um,
but that's probably going to change
because Brooklyn is getting awfully
expensive to the point where it's
definitely in competition with
Manhattan,
uh,
especially the savory parts.
And,
uh,
so I don't know.
I wonder in a few years,
are we going to have the,
the queen's writer,
you know,
and then far into the future when the
Staten Island writer,
you know,
if it's scary.
Um,
but what I don't like about it is that
it takes so much attention from all the
writers that don't even live in New
York.
That's one thing about the book tour
that was so interesting to me and about
the friendships that I've forged with
the writers who live all over this
country.
And,
and,
you know,
I think I always thought that as a
writer,
you need it to live here,
you know?
And,
and even recently,
I thought it's a good idea to be near my
editor,
my agent,
or to,
you know,
and it's,
it's sort of a fallacy.
Um,
so I,
I don't like the feeling that I don't
like spreading the,
the sort of idea that,
that writers need to live,
if not in the Manhattan,
then right by it.
Um,
because the beauty is now you can,
for the most part,
live everywhere anywhere you want.
Um,
but,
um,
I do love Brooklyn and I like,
and I like my,
my new neighborhood and Kensington,
there's a lot of,
it was a very vibrant Middle Eastern
community there that I can spy on,
which is fun.
Um,
and you get a great diversity in
Brooklyn,
um,
and it is affordable and it's beautiful.
So it's a formula.